[Applause]
the year is 1955 South Korea is a
corrupt and unstable country that
depends heavily on foreign aid
devastated by the war South Korea was at
the time the third poorest country in
all of Asia its per capita income
equaled that of African countries such
as Ghana and it was enduring the highest
inflation and lowest growth rate in the
entire region ruled with an iron fist by
the authoritarian General Park chung-hee
from 1961 expectations for this country
were not great South Korea in the 60s
was a country of emigrants since even
its northern neighbor looks more
promising just a second because that's
certainly not how things look today
[Music]
nowadays South Korea is the country of
kpop k-beauty k-fashion and cave dramas
in short we're talking about a country
that's become trendy folks the Korean
Wave also known as howyou has reached
virtually every corner of the globe
not sure if I'm pronouncing how are you
right there my magical pronunciation
dictionary doesn't have it and I'm not
up to scratch on South Korean culture
now don't think that it's only culture
that has been exported not at all South
Korean companies such as Samsung Hyundai
or LG have also extended their tentacles
across all five continents
[Music]
[Applause]
please
and that's no small feat South Korea has
been one of the greatest economic
success stories of all time in a little
over three decades that's just one
generation South Korea went from being a
third world country to becoming one of
the richest and most prosperous
countries on the planet
[Music]
so the question is how did South Korea
manage this development how did it
manage to become such a rich country
well actually no that's not the question
we're going to be answering today
because what we've already answered that
question in another video which I'm
gonna link to in the description in a
nutshell it was thanks to the unique
South Korean developer model which is
characterized by large industrial groups
the key balls along with a very
demanding educational system and open
approach to the world at large
accumulation of capital and active
technological absorption policies and
this all led to the so-called South
Korean economic miracle
in 2017 this man won at the elections
the current president moon jae-in with a
fistful of new policies that he promised
would turn South Korea's economic model
around and we aren't talking about
conventional policies far from it
so listen up
[Music]
an exhausted model
yes nowadays South Korea is one of the
richest countries on the planet and its
economy it continues to grow but his
model is flawed and many indicators show
a negative trend for example it is
expected that in 2019 the country will
record the lowest growth of the last
seven years its unemployment registered
a nine year low in January wages aren't
increasing and young people are finding
it harder and harder to get a job none
of this has been very common in South
Korea over the last thirty years
unfortunately because we ourselves do
not see the future of Korea as so rosy I
do not want to bring up children in the
Sun promising society I think that
mentality is persistent among many of my
peers bong song dilk a civil engineering
doctoral student this alone should be
cause for concern right well the hold on
a minute because there's a whole lot
more
[Music]
households South Korean families
accumulate debt equivalent to almost a
hundred percent of the gross domestic
product which makes them the most
leveraged households in any country in
the world because yes South Koreans do
save a lot but they also invest a lot
especially in housing and on top of that
most jobs are so unproductive that the
workday extends well into the evening
and I'm talking about a couple of hours
overtime here check this out
[Music]
south korea cuts quote inhumanely long
68 hour working week president
introduces 52 hour work week to help
improve quality of life and boost birth
rates if I don't work overtime my pay
gets reduced I'd rather work more to get
paid more lee myung real a 37 year old
who earns eighteen hundred dollars a
month at womb BTS as you can see this
model is quite unsustainable and this
it's just the tip of the iceberg you see
the South Korean economy has some
characteristics that we need to take
into account on the one hand South
Korea's economy is divided so to speak
into two main parts there's the huge key
bars which are extremely important the
ten largest groups alone generate more
than 40 percent of its GDP actually
forty four point two percent in 2018
these groups are received favors and
privileges from the government's they
control financial institutions and they
have behaviors that seek to limit
competition within the country
then there's the SMEs that's the small
and medium-sized enterprises more than
3.5 million people have companies that
have no privileges and are subject to
the enormous power key boss this is a
situation that has very significant
consequences
for example the average SME salary which
is what most South Koreans earn is
approximately half that of the large
company salaries and all the gap it just
keeps on growing why well because among
other things the big key balls behave in
a monopolistic way and there are many
suspicions of collusion between these
groups and various politicians it goes
something like this the directors of one
large group agree with the directors of
another group and get some politicians
involved in order to limit the
competition and share the market between
them faced with this situation you can
already imagine that the power of our
SMEs is enormous if they don't accept
the key balls conditions they simply
have to shut down and this isn't just a
matter of salary differences in recent
years the number of SMEs that have
declared bankruptcy has grown
exponentially as if that weren't enough
the technological development of
countries like China is also increasing
competition and putting pressure on the
South Korean economy which is extremely
dependent on exports
well this is causing the key balls to
transfer part of their production to
other countries and replace local
suppliers with foreign suppliers Korean
companies can't compete with China and
India on price and should move up the
value chain but the industrial evolution
towards higher value-added products is
not happening in the SME sector because
of their reliance on the conglomerates
Park sung in an economics professor at
Seoul National University to see an
example of this we need look no further
than the automotive industry South Korea
is one of the largest car manufacturers
in the world but in spite of the surge
that the sector has experienced in
recent years
South Korean production has been falling
for the last three consecutive years
why because founder which controls
seventy percent of the national market
is moving its production and suppliers
to countries like Mexico and India in
the end folks the privileges that the
government is given to these groups and
the actions that they have taken to
limit competition have meant that most
jobs are tied to unproductive companies
with little efficiency and little
investments in research and innovation
and of course if you don't have those
things then you can't compete with
countries like China or Vietnam which
have much lower labor costs and all of
this well is generating a lot of fear in
South Korea thus it was precisely first
promise to solve these problems that
moon jae-in
the current president won the elections
in 2017 and you know what he's got a bit
of an unconventional plan so how does
moon jae-in want to rescue South Korea
well check this out
[Music]
president moon jae-in's plan D viewer
moon Jane has promised to reform South
Korea's economic model from top to
bottom he isn't planning on doing it
with the typical solutions of lower
taxes or less regulation in fact quite
the opposite
the South Korean president's plan is
based fundamentally on two pillars the
first consists of what its support is
called democratizing the economy in
practice this consists of raising taxes
increasing public spending public
employments and the minimum wage and
this isn't exactly happening in small
quantities see in 2019 public spending
will grow by more than 10 percent which
is the largest increase in a decade on
the other hand the minimum wage grew by
sixteen point four percent in 2018 and
in 2019 will rise by an additional ten
point nine percent can the government
has already said that the raises they're
not going to end there in order to
finance more state spending in the
hiring of 850,000 new public employees
moon jaein has boosted the corporate
profits tax which will go from 22 to 25
percent and he's also going to raise
taxes on the highest wages
the idea that the government has is that
all these measures will raise families
income ends with its consumption this
would reduce the dependence of South
Korean companies on exports the problem
while folks it's just not working see
since moon jae-in began taking these
measures the economy has begun to slow
down unemployment has started to grow
and to top it all off lower family
incomes are actually falling yep you
heard that right their salaries are
increasing but many workers have lost
their jobs so the net result is the 20%
of families with fewer resources and
less money today than they did before
the minimum wage rise all this explains
why the president's approval ratings
have dropped from 84 percent in mid 2017
to 45 percent today the folks before we
finish there's another great pillar in
the South Korean president's strategy
and we need to look at it now so listen
up
[Music]
looking north
folks the South Korean president is
convinced that his country's future
involves North Korea we are at the
historical start line toward common
prosperity on the Korean Peninsula and
Northeast Asia this is an opportunity
that has come like a miracle it is a
chance that we should never miss moon
jae-in
[Music]
to see this map in it you could see moon
jae-in's plans for North Korea he wants
to promote three large economic belts to
connect South Korea's industrial core
with North Korea with China and with
Russia through new rail lines roads gas
pipelines electrical networks etc the
investments needed to implement just the
new trains would amount to more than 40
billion dollars Korea anticipates that
the trans-siberian railway will again
reach Busan the southern tip of the
Korean Peninsula where I grew up
building on the permanent peace on the
peninsula moon jae-in and an address to
the Russian Duma
[Music]
folks with all of these projects the
president wants to improve the South
Korean economies commercial capabilities
while giving his companies access to
North Korea's resources and labor see
it's estimated that North Korean workers
monthly salary is around $60 which is
much less than what Chinese or
Vietnamese workers charge for Samsung
Electronics North Korea is a good
candidate to set up production lines
because it can offer cheap labor has no
language barrier and has the same time
zone yu seungmin
chief strategist at Samsung Securities
the problem well moon jae-in isn't
having much luck here either while
negotiations between North Korea and the
United States going slowly South Korean
companies aren't convinced about
investing billions of dollars in North
Korea in the short term especially
because they don't trust Kim Jong Un's
regime I know there's the last question
he was going to pay the huge price tag
required to carry out these plans
so to recap this is the recipe with
which moon jae-in wants to transform the
South Korean economic model more taxes
more public spending more public
employments higher minimum wages and
developments in North Korea do you think
it'll work well leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
if you did please do hit that like
button and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos for soap don't forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine also this channel is possible
because of patreon and our patrons on
that platform please do consider joining
them and supporting our mission of
providing independent political coverage
and as always I'll see you in the next
video
[Music]